Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采贡献了大量的碳排放，因此六大公司携手合作，在迈向净零排放的道路上取得进展。他们投资于技术和创新，每桶原油的平均排放量已经减少了22%，并与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位，还开发了世界上最大的碳捕集与储存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，并且我们在多个途径上都取得了进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 亲眼见证我们的计划。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. It was around dinner time on Friday, May 21, 2010, when Julie Kibuwishi received a text message. Can you come over tonight at midnight alone? Very upset. Need to talk. Julie typed a reply asking what was the matter. After making her promise that she wouldn't tell anyone, the sender explained that they were hurting due to some bad family crap.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。那是2010年5月21日星期五的晚餐时间左右，朱莉·基布伊什（Julie Kibuwishi）收到了一条短信：“今晚能一个人过来吗？我很心烦，需要聊聊。”朱莉打字回复询问出了什么事。在让她保证不告诉任何人后，发信人解释说他们因为一些糟糕的家庭破事而感到痛苦。
A short while later, Julie's cell phone lit up again. Where are you? Can you come by? I don't want to be up late. It was approaching midnight when Julie pulled up to the Camden-Martinac apartments in the Californian city of Costa Mesa. The sprawling residential complex consisted of multiple low-rise buildings interspersed with winding walkways and palm trees. After parking her car, Julie headed towards one of the buildings while texting, Hey buddy, I am here. I am walking to your place. Then, as she reached the right floor, she messaged her brother, Taka, to let him know she'd arrived safely at her destination. As Julie typed, she heard a strange sound from the other side of an apartment door.
不久之后，朱莉的手机再次亮起：“你在哪？能过来吗？我不想熬夜。”接近午夜时分，朱莉将车停在了加利福尼亚州科斯塔梅萨市的卡姆登-马蒂纳克（Camden-Martinac）公寓楼外。这个错落有致的住宅区由多栋低层建筑组成，其间点缀着蜿蜒的小路和棕榈树。停好车后，朱莉一边发短信“嘿，老兄，我到了。我正朝你家走去”，一边走向其中一栋建筑。接着，当她到达正确的楼层时，她给哥哥塔卡（Taka）发了消息，告知他自己已经安全到达目的地。就在朱莉打字的时候，她听到公寓门的那头传来了奇怪的声音。
It sounded like a person sobbing. Signing off her message to Taka, Julie wrote, Sam is crying. It's not good. A few hours earlier, 23-year-old Julie Kibuwishi had been out of town. She said, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
听起来像是一个人在抽泣。朱莉结束了给塔卡的留言，写道：“萨姆在哭，情况不太妙。”几小时前，23岁的朱莉·基布伊什还一直在外地。“我很抱歉。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。”
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. A few hours earlier, 23-year-old Julie Kibuwishi had been out with her brother Taka and his fiance in Long Beach, not far from where she lived in Irvine, Orange County. The trio were dining at a Thai restaurant near Taka's home. It was a special occasion. Taka and his fiance had a very important request to make of Julie.
“我很抱歉。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。”几小时前，23岁的朱莉·基布伊什还和她的哥哥塔卡以及他的未婚妻在长滩外出，离她居住的橙县尔湾不远。三人在塔卡家附近的一家泰国餐厅用餐。这是一个特殊的日子，塔卡和他的未婚妻对朱莉有一个非常重要的请求。
Julie was born on Valentine's Day in 1987, and others jokingly said that this was the reason she was a hopeless romantic. So, when Julie was asked to be a bridesmaid at her brother's upcoming wedding, she was overcome with the joy. After she happily accepted the offer, Taka handed his sister a tiara. It was both a gift and the finishing touch for her bridesmaid outfit. Julie put it on at once. After dinner, the trio headed back to Taka's home to continue chatting.
朱莉于1987年的情人节出生，别人开玩笑说这就是她无可救药地充满浪漫主义情怀的原因。因此，当朱莉被邀请在她哥哥即将到来的婚礼上担任伴娘时，她欣喜若狂。在她愉快地接受了这个请求后，塔卡递给他的妹妹一顶头饰。这既是一份礼物，也是她伴娘装扮的点睛之笔。朱莉立刻戴上了它。晚餐后，三人回到塔卡的家继续聊天。
Julie wasn't planning on staying long though. During dinner, her red Samsung cellphone had lit up with text messages from a close friend named Sam Hare. The two had met at Orange Coast Community College where they both took anthropology. Julie had tutored Sam in the subject, helping him achieve an A in that class. According to Sam's texts, he was having a rough night. After some back and forth, Julie told Sam she would leave her brother's house to visit him right away. She respected Sam's request to come alone, and after a short drive, Julie arrived at the Camden Martinique apartments in Costa Mesa where Sam lived.
不过，朱莉并没有打算待太久。晚饭期间，她的红色三星手机闪烁着来自一位名叫萨姆·黑尔（Sam Hare）的密友的短信。两人是在橙海岸社区学院认识的，当时他们都选修了人类学。朱莉曾在这门课上辅导过萨姆，帮他在那门课上取得了A的成绩。根据萨姆的短信，他度过了一个糟糕的夜晚。经过一番微信往返，朱莉告诉萨姆她会离开哥哥家立刻去探望他。她尊重萨姆独自前来的请求，经过短暂的车程，朱莉抵达了萨姆居住的位于科斯塔梅萨的卡姆登马提尼克公寓。
The following morning, Junco Kibuishi stood at the door to her daughter Julie's bedroom. The bed inside had not been slept in, and there was no sign of Julie anywhere else in the house. It wasn't like Julie to disappear without telling her parents where she would be. Family had always been of the utmost importance to her. Born into a close-knit Japanese-American household, Julie was the third of four children and had two older brothers. When Julie's mother Junco was pregnant with her, she was told that her third child would be a boy as well. Julie was therefore an unexpected, though happy surprise to her parents. They named her Juri, but as their first daughter grew older, she was more commonly known to her friends by the Americanized version of her name, Julie.
第二天早上，纯子·基布伊什（Junco Kibuishi）站在女儿朱莉的卧室门口。里面的床没有被睡过，屋里其他地方也没有朱莉的踪影。朱莉向来不会在不告诉父母去哪里的情况下消失。家庭对她来说一直是最重要的。朱莉出生在一个关系紧密的日裔美国家庭，是四个孩子中的老三，有两个哥哥。当朱莉的母亲纯子怀着她时，有人告诉她第三个孩子也会是个男孩。因此，对父母来说，朱莉是一个意外却充满喜悦的惊喜。他们给她起名叫Juri，但随着大女儿的长大，朋友们更习惯用她名字的美国化称呼——朱莉。
Now unable to find Julie anywhere, Junco followed up with her friends, but none could shed any light on where she might be. When texts and calls to Julie's cell phone continued to go unanswered, Junco was certain something was wrong and contacted the police. At the same time that Julie's family were worrying about her, a couple who lived in the Orange County neighborhood of Anaheim Hills were wondering where their son might be. Steve and Raquel Herr had been expecting a visit from their only child, Samuel, better known as Sam. He spent many weekends with his parents, who were only a 30-minute drive away from his Costa Mesa apartment. Raquel had spoken with Sam over the phone around lunchtime the previous day, and he hadn't given any indication that he intended to change his plans. The couple tried calling Sam periodically throughout the day, but his cell phone was switched off. This seemed odd. They had never known Sam to turn off his phone. By late evening, Steve Herr was standing at the front door to his son's apartment.
现在到处都找不到朱莉，纯子便联系了她的朋友们，但没有人能透露她可能在哪里。当打给朱莉手机的短信和电话依然无人接听时，纯子确信出事了，于是联系了警方。就在朱莉的家人为她担心的同时，一对住在橙县安纳海姆山社区的夫妇正在纳闷他们的儿子会在哪。史蒂夫·黑尔（Steve Herr）和拉奎尔·黑尔（Raquel Herr）一直期待着他们唯一的孩子塞缪尔（Samuel，人称萨姆）来拜访。他经常和父母度过周末，父母的家距离他在科斯塔梅萨的公寓只有30分钟的车程。前一天午餐时间左右，拉奎尔曾通过电话与萨姆交谈过，他当时没有表现出任何要改变计划的迹象。这对夫妇一整天都在断断续续地给萨姆打电话，但他的手机关机了。这显得很奇怪。他们从来没遇到过萨姆关机的情况。到了深夜，史蒂夫·黑尔站在了儿子公寓的前门外。
Using a spare key Sam had given him, Steve let himself in to check that everything was alright. The lights were on, but all was quiet. Nothing looked out of place. Sam's apartment was a typical sparsely furnished bachelor pad. His acoustic guitar was perched in its stand in a lounge. Some blankets were folded up at the end of the sofa, and textbooks sat on a bookcase. Everything was neat and tidy. In the kitchen, some washed dishes had been left on a drying rack, and mail sat stacked on a countertop. Empty beer bottles were scattered by the barbecue out on the patio. Despite the seemingly normal scene in front of him, Steve felt strange, as though someone else were in the apartment with him. He called out his son's name, Sammy.
史蒂夫用萨姆给他的备用钥匙打开门，进去检查一切是否安好。灯亮着，但四周一片寂静。没有什么东西看起来不妥。萨姆的公寓是一个典型的陈设简陋的单身汉居所。他的原声吉他立在休息室的支架上，沙发头叠着几条毯子，书架上放着教科书。一切都整洁有序。在厨房里，一些洗好的盘子放在沥水架上，台面上堆着信件。露台的烧烤炉旁散落着空啤酒瓶。尽管眼前的场景看起来很正常，但史蒂夫觉得很奇怪，仿佛公寓里还有别的人。他大声喊着儿子的名字：“萨姆。”
Then, as Steve looked into Sam's bedroom, he was met with a horrifying sight. Alongside Sam's messy and unmade bed was a young woman. She was kneeling, her torso sprawled over the mattress, and her lower legs resting on the floor. Her jeans had been cut at the waistband and down through the seat, before being ripped down around her knees. A message had been scribbled in black marker across the back of a grey top she was still wearing. It read, quote, All yours, fuck you. The back of her head was bloody, as were the sheets beneath her.
接着，当史蒂夫朝萨姆的卧室看去时，他看到了恐怖的一幕。在萨姆凌乱且未整理的床铺旁躺着一名年轻女子。她跪着，上半身趴在床垫上，小腿贴着地板。她的牛仔裤在腰带处被剪开，一直剪到臀部，然后被撕扯到膝盖周围。她身上穿的一件灰色上衣的背面用黑色马克笔潦草地写着一句话。上面写着，引述：“全归你了，操你妈。”她脑后满是鲜血，底下的床单也是如此。
Steve saw what he recognized as a gunshot wound in her scalp. Sitting on top of her head in her long matted black hair was a tiara. Steve knew without a doubt that the woman was dead. Panicked, he pulled out his cell phone and dialed 911. When the operator answered, he cried out in a distraught voice. There's a body in my son's apartment. Steve recognized the deceased woman as his son's close friend and anthropology tutor, Julie Kibuishi. He had met Julie before and thought she was a lovely young woman.
史蒂夫看到他认出是头皮上的枪伤。她那长而打结的黑发顶部戴着一顶头饰。史蒂夫毫不怀疑这个女人已经死了。惊慌失措之下，他掏出手机拨打了911。接线员接听时，他痛苦地哭喊道：“我儿子的公寓里有一具尸体。”史蒂夫认出死者是他儿子的密友兼人类学导师朱莉·基布伊什。他以前见过朱莉，觉得她是个可爱的年轻女子。
Noting how well she got on with Sam, Steve later asked his son if there was a romantic connection between them. Sam had dismissed the notion, telling his father that Julie was more like a sister to him. But it looked as though some sort of sexual activity had taken place in Sam's room. When police arrived on the scene, they made the same observation. The way Julie's body was posed and the aggressive removal of her pants indicated that she had been sexually assaulted, then brutally executed. An autopsy later revealed Julie had been shot twice in the head. The message that had been scrawled on her back, or yours, fuck you, seemed pointed, as though directed at a particular person. Investigators suspected a love triangle.
注意到她和萨姆相处得很好，史蒂夫后来问他的儿子他们之间是否有恋情。萨姆对此不以为然，告诉父亲朱莉对她来说更像是妹妹。但看起来萨姆的房间里似乎发生某种性行为。当警察到达现场时，他们也做出了同样的观察。朱莉尸体呈现的姿势以及裤子被粗暴脱下的方式表明她曾遭受性侵，随后被残忍处决。尸检后来显示朱莉头部中了两枪。写在她背上的那句话“全归你了，操你妈”似乎意有所指，仿佛是针对特定的人。调查人员怀疑这是一起三角恋。
Most likely, Sam had been competing for Julie's affections with another individual. Upon searching Sam's room, they found what appeared to be a sex manual, as well as a soldier's handbook. The latter made sense. Prior to enrolling at college when he was 26 years old, Sam Hare had served in the United States Army's 173rd Airborne Brigade Combat Team. He had been sent to Afghanistan and spent much of his time there fighting on the border with Pakistan, in a particularly dangerous region that was constantly under fire. When he returned to the US, Sam exhibited symptoms of post-traumatic stress disorder, suffering from regular nightmares where he was trapped in a foxhole while insurgents bore down on him. Eager to move on with his life, he enrolled in college so he could obtain a degree. In addition to the books, investigators recovered a clean knife with a wide, partially serrated blade.
最有可能的是，萨姆一直在与另一个人争夺朱莉的爱慕。在搜查萨姆的房间时，他们发现了一本疑似性爱手册以及一本士兵手册。后者说得通。萨姆·黑尔在26岁入读大学之前，曾在美国陆军第173空降旅战斗队服役。他被派往阿富汗，大部分时间都在巴基斯坦边境作战，那是一个不断遭到炮火袭击的极其危险的地区。回到美国后，萨姆表现出创伤后应激障碍的症状，经常做噩梦，梦见自己被困在散兵坑里，而叛乱分子步步紧逼。急于继续生活，他考入大学以获取学位。除了书籍之外，调查人员还找到了一把干净的刀，刀刃很宽，带有部分锯齿。
Julie's handbag was found in the kitchen with her driver's license and cell phone inside. An examination of Julie's phone revealed how Sam had repeatedly reached out to her the previous night. In a series of text messages, he'd begged her to come over to his place while also insisting that she come alone and tell no one. Investigators noted how Sam had reassured Julie that his desire to see her wasn't sexual, writing in one message, Please, no sex. Sam's cell phone, wallet and passport were nowhere to be found. His car, a white Pontiac, was also missing. Investigators ran a background check on Sam Hare to find out who exactly they were dealing with.
朱莉的手提包在厨房里被发现，里面有她的驾照和手机。对朱莉手机的检查显示前一晚萨姆是如何多次联系她的。在一系列短信中，他恳求她去他家，同时坚持要她一个人来，并且不要告诉任何人。调查人员注意到萨姆是如何向朱莉保证他想见她并非出于性欲，他在一条消息中写道：“求你了，不要发生性行为。”萨姆的手机、钱包和护照都不翼而飞。他的车，一辆白色的庞蒂亚克，也不见了。调查人员对萨姆·黑尔进行了背景调查，以弄清楚他们究竟在和谁打交道。
As well as learning that Sam was an army veteran with extensive combat experience, they made another, more disturbing discovery. Eight years earlier in 2002, Sam Hare had been charged with murder. At the time, Sam was 18 years old. He had been friends with another young man named Byron Benito who had gang affiliations. Authorities said that after some gang members suspected Byron of shooting one of their friends, Sam Hare helped them by luring Byron to a secluded industrial estate. According to police, after Sam and Byron arrived there, a group of assailants attacked Byron, stabbing and beating him to death. For his role in the plot, Sam Hare was charged with murder and spent almost a year in custody before going to trial in 2004.
在得知萨姆是一名拥有丰富作战经验的退役军人之外，他们还有了另一个更令人不安的发现。八年前的2002年，萨姆·黑尔曾被指控谋杀。当时萨姆18岁。他曾与另一个有黑帮背景的年轻男子拜伦·贝尼托（Byron Benito）是朋友。当局表示，在一些黑帮成员怀疑拜伦枪杀了一名同伴后，萨姆·黑尔通过诱骗拜伦到一个偏僻的工业园区协助了他们。据警方称，萨姆和拜伦到达那里后，一群袭击者袭击了拜伦，将其刺死并殴打致死。因在阴谋中扮演的角色，萨姆·黑尔被控谋杀，在候审前被关押了近一年，直到2004年出庭受审。
The prosecution argued that while Sam hadn't physically hurt Byron, he had taken him to the side of his death with full knowledge of what would unfold. Unconvinced that these actions proved Sam guilty of murder, a jury ultimately acquitted him. Relieved and determined to start a new life, Sam enlisted in the army and went on to become a decorated veteran. Despite his full exoneration, Sam's history was notable to the detectives investigating him for the murder of Julie Kibuwishi almost a decade later. Similarities between the two crimes were clear. Byron and Julie were close friends of Sam and both had met a violent end after Sam lured them to a predetermined destination. At this point, locating Sam became a matter of public safety. Physically fit and strongly built, Sam was more than capable of defending himself if necessary. Then there was his military combat experience as well as the likelihood that he was armed with a gun.
控方辩称，虽然萨姆没有对拜伦造成物理伤害，但他是在完全知晓会发生什么的情况下将拜伦带到了丧命之地。由于不确信这些行为证明萨姆犯有谋杀罪，陪审团最终宣告他无罪。如释重负并决心开始新生活的萨姆参军入伍，后来成为了一名荣立战功的退役军人。尽管已被完全开脱，但萨姆的过往对于近十年后调查朱莉·基布伊什谋杀案的侦探来说依然引人注目。两起罪行的相似之处显而易见。拜伦和朱莉都是萨姆的密友，在萨姆将他们诱骗至预定地点后，两人都迎来了暴力的结局。此时，找到萨姆成了一个公共安全问题。身体健硕、体格强壮的萨姆在必要时完全有能力保护自己。然后还有他的军事战斗经验，以及他很可能持有枪支的可能性。
Investigators had to move quickly. They interviewed everyone who knew Sam, including a number of neighbors who lived in the Camden-Martinac apartments. Due to most of the residents being college students around the same age, the apartments had a thriving social scene and many of the people who lived there were friendly with one another. One man who lived a couple of floors below Sam said he'd seen him the afternoon before Julie was murdered. Sam had helped him move some heavy items, then he'd left Camden-Martinac with a man Sam's neighbor had never seen before. The man was white and wore a black baseball cap. The neighbor's fiance confirmed this sighting, adding that the man didn't live at the apartments and she had never seen him before. Meanwhile, Sam's father, Steve, was struggling with the sudden disappearance of his son.
调查人员必须迅速行动。他们采访了所有认识萨姆的人，包括住在卡姆登-马蒂纳克公寓的一群邻居。由于大多数居民都是年纪相仿的大学生，公寓有着繁荣的社交圈，许多住在那里的人彼此都很友好。一个住在萨姆楼下几层的男子说，他在朱莉被谋杀的前一天下午见过他。萨姆曾帮他搬了一些重物，然后和另一个萨姆的邻居从未见过的人离开了卡姆登-马蒂纳克。那名男子是个白人，戴着黑色棒球帽。邻居的未婚妻证实了这次目击，并补充说该男子不住在公寓里，她以前从未见过他。与此同时，萨姆的父亲史蒂夫正艰难面对儿子突如其来的失踪。
Determined to track him down, he began carrying out his own private investigation. Sam had previously provided his father with all of his online banking details and passwords in case of an emergency. On Monday, May 24, when Sam had been missing for two days, Steve logged into his son's bank account. Almost right away, Steve noticed that there had been lots of activity. Over the past few days, Sam had repeatedly withdrawn funds from an ATM in Long Beach. Each time, he opted to take out $400, the maximum amount his bank permitted him to withdraw in a day. Overall, these increments had added up to almost $2,000. Steve then drove to Long Beach in the hopes of catching Sam in the act.
为了找到他，他开始进行自己的私下调查。萨姆此前曾将自己所有的网上银行详细信息和密码提供给父亲，以防万一。5月24日星期一，当萨姆失踪已经两天时，史蒂夫登录了儿子的银行账户。几乎立刻，史蒂夫注意到有大量的活动。在过去的几天里，萨姆多次从长滩的一台自动取款机提取资金。每次，他都选择取出400美元，这是他的银行允许一天内取款的最大额度。总体而言，这些零星的金额加起来近2000美元。史蒂夫随后开车前往长滩，希望能抓萨姆一个现行。
He staked out the city's ATMs but didn't see his son. Then he drove around the area's streets and roads, keeping a lookout for Sam's white Pontiac. There was no sign of it. Suddenly, a notification came through on Steve's phone from Sam's bank. Sam's bank card had just been used to order some pizzas from a Long Beach pizza parlor named Echoes. Steve rushed to the restaurant. It sat along a busy six-lane thoroughfare with tables and umbrellas set out along the pavement for outdoor dining. Steve parked in front of Echoes and alternated between watching its glass door entrance and keeping an eye out for Sam's car.
他在该市的自动取款机旁蹲守，但没有看到儿子。然后他在该地区的街道和小路上开车巡视，寻找萨姆白色的庞蒂亚克。毫无踪影。突然，史蒂夫的手机上收到了来自萨姆银行的通知。萨姆的银行卡刚刚被用来从长滩一家名为“回声”（Echoes）的比萨店订购了一些比萨。史蒂夫冲向餐馆。它位于一条繁忙的六车道大道旁，人行道上摆着桌子和遮阳伞供户外用餐。史蒂夫把车停在“回声”门前，在监视其玻璃门入口和留意萨姆的车之间来回切换。
He waited for an hour. Although other patrons came and went, his son never appeared. The case detectives had also gained access to Sam's banking records and were also keeping a watch on account activity. Like Steve, they had noted the repeated withdrawals being made from Long Beach. There had been four separate withdrawals from two different Chase Bank ATMs. The machines had cameras fitted inside and investigators were able to obtain the surveillance footage from both. Upon examining the footage recorded at the exact times Sam's card had been used, detectives were perplexed. Standing before the machine was a teenage boy. He was white and looked very young, dressed in a hoodie and a black baseball cap.
他等了一个小时。尽管其他顾客来来往往，但他的儿子始终没有出现。案件侦探也获取了萨姆的银行记录，并在监视账户活动。和史蒂夫一样，他们注意到了从长滩进行的反复提款。从两家不同的大通银行自动取款机进行了四次独立的提款。这些机器内部装有摄像头，调查人员能够从两处获取监控录像。在检查萨姆的卡被使用的准确时间录制的录像时，侦探们感到困惑。站在机器前的是一个十几岁的男孩。他是个白人，看起来非常年轻，穿着连帽衫和黑色棒球帽。
Was this the individual in the black hat that Sam's neighbours had seen him with on the day of Julie's murder? The detectives didn't recognise him and nor did Sam's parents when they were shown a photo. Investigators contacted Echo's pizza parlor where Sam's card had been used to make a purchase and asked for the delivery address provided for that particular order. Once they had it, a full SWAT team descended on the property and a helicopter was dispatched for an aerial view. If Sam Hare was hiding inside, the investigators didn't want to take any chances. The last thing they needed was a hostage situation on their hands. Judging from the noises emanating from the house, a party was in full swing. When the occupants were ordered to open up, the teenage boy who had been caught on the ATMs camera opened the front door.
这就是朱莉被谋杀那天萨姆的邻居们看到的那个戴黑帽子的男子吗？侦探们不认识他，萨姆的父母在看到照片时也不认识。调查人员联系了使用萨姆的卡进行购买的“回声”比萨店，并索取了该特定订单提供的送货地址。一旦拿到地址，整支特警队便突袭了该物业，并派出一架直升机进行空中观察。如果萨姆·黑尔藏在里面，调查人员绝不愿冒险。他们最不需要的就是发生人质事件。从屋里传出的噪音判断，一场派对正在热烈进行。当勒令屋内的人开门时，那个被自动取款机摄像头拍到的十几岁男孩打开了前门。
His name was Wesley and he was 17 years old. He lived there with his mother who was a drama teacher. Wesley was ordered out of the house along with his friends whom he'd invited over to play video games and instructed to get down on the ground. As he lay on the front lawn, officers filed inside to conduct a thorough search, determined that they would flush out Sam Hare from wherever he was hiding. After examining each room, it was clear Sam Hare wasn't in the house, but his debit card was. When confronted with Sam's debit card, Wesley denied having used it or even knowing anything about it. Are you sure about that, one of the officers asked? This card's tied to a homicide. Wesley's demeanor immediately changed. He looked visibly scared as he repeated the words, a homicide. It didn't take long for him to spill what he knew.
他的名字叫韦斯利（Wesley），今年17岁。他和当戏剧老师的母亲住在这里。韦斯利和被他请来玩电子游戏的朋一起被命令走出屋子，并被指示趴在地上。当他躺在前草坪上时，警官们排队进入屋内进行彻底搜查，决心无论萨姆·黑尔藏在哪里都要把他逼出来。在检查了每个房间后，很明显萨姆·黑尔不在屋里，但他的借记卡在。当面对萨姆的借记卡时，韦斯利否认自己使用过它，甚至否认对此事知情。“你确定吗？”其中一名警官问。“这张卡跟一桩凶杀案有关。”韦斯利的神态立刻变了。他看起来明显很害怕，重复着“凶杀案”这个词。没花多久他就吐露了他所知道的一切。
Wesley didn't know Sam Hare. He had been withdrawing the money on behalf of someone else. 26-year-old Daniel Wozniak lived at the Camden-Martineke apartments, a couple of floors below Sam Hare's residence. He had held a few different jobs here and there, but his true passion was acting. Daniel's performances in community theatre productions had been positively received, and he was currently starring in the lead role in a several-month-long run of the musical Nine at an alternative theatre company in Orange County. He and Sam Hare became friendly after Daniel and his fiance, Rachel Buffett, a fellow aspiring actor, had moved into the complex several months earlier in February. They shared a circle of friends at Camden-Martineke and socialized regularly. Daniel was the downstairs neighbour who had mentioned seeing Sam leave with a man in a black baseball cap on the day of Julie Kibawishi's murder.
韦斯利不认识萨姆·黑尔。他是替别人取钱的。26岁的丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克（Daniel Wozniak）住在卡姆登-马蒂尼克公寓，在萨姆·黑尔住所楼下几层。他在这里那里做过几份不同的工作，但他真正的热情是表演。丹尼尔在社区剧院制作中的表演受到了好评，目前他正在橙县的一家另类剧院公司长达数月的音乐剧《九》（Nine）中担任主角。他和萨姆·黑尔在丹尼尔和他的未婚妻蕾切尔·布菲（Rachel Buffett，同为有抱负的演员）几个月前的2月搬进该综合大楼后成为了朋友。他们在卡姆登-马蒂尼克分享了一个朋友圈并经常社交。丹尼尔就是那个提到在朱莉·基博伊什被谋杀当天看到萨姆和一个戴黑色棒球帽的男子离开的楼下邻居。
Initially, this had appeared to be a helpful clue in the search for Sam. Now, investigators viewed Daniel's story far more critically. 17-year-old Wesley had since accused Daniel of supplying him with Sam's bank card under the order to drain the account. Was Daniel helping Sam evade authorities? If so, was he aware of what exactly his friend was running from? Detectives called Daniel Wozniak's cell phone seeking an explanation. He answered, but said that he couldn't speak with them that night because he was at his bachelor party. In two days' time, on Friday, May 28, Daniel was getting married, and he had gone out to a Japanese restaurant with a few friends to celebrate. Investigators didn't care. With Sam Hare still a threat to the public, they needed to speak with Daniel right away.
最初，这似乎是搜寻萨姆的一个有用线索。现在，调查人员对丹尼尔的故事持更批判的眼光。17岁的韦斯利此后指控丹尼尔给他提供了萨姆的银行卡，命令他掏空该账户。丹尼尔是在帮萨姆逃避当局吗？如果是这样，他是否知道他的朋友究竟在逃避什么？侦探们给丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克的手机打去电话寻求解释。他接了电话，但说他今晚不能跟他们谈，因为他在参加单身汉派对。两天后的5月28日星期五，丹尼尔就要结婚了，他和小伙伴们出去到一家日本餐厅庆祝。侦探们可不管这些。由于萨姆·黑尔对公众仍然是个威胁，他们需要立刻与丹尼尔谈谈。
Detective Jose Morales approached the beige single-story building that housed Sonami Sushi. Located on the Pacific Coast Highway in Huntington Beach, the restaurant often hosted parties, with its teppanyaki grill a popular attraction. Detective Morales entered the establishment alone. In his plain clothes, he wouldn't attract much attention. The detective walked through the front door and strolled around the bar area, scanning the room that Daniel Wozniak. He couldn't see him. Then, towards the back of the restaurant in a private banquet room, he spotted him. Daniel was dressed in khaki pants and a Hawaiian shirt, laughing as he drank sake with his friends. Detective Morales radioed for backup, and more officers soon arrived at the scene. They waited until Daniel had paid for the meal, then entered through the restaurant's rear door and filed into the banquet room.
何塞·莫拉莱斯侦探（Detective Jose Morales）走近了容纳“园美寿司”（Sonami Sushi）的米色单层建筑。该餐厅位于亨廷顿海滩的太平洋海岸公路旁，经常举办派对，其铁板烧烤架是一个受欢迎的吸引点。莫拉莱斯侦探独自进入了这家店。穿着便服的他不会引起太多注意。侦探走过前门，在酒吧区闲逛，扫视着丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克。他看不到他。然后，在餐厅后面的一个私人宴会厅里，他发现了目标。丹尼尔穿着卡其裤和夏威夷衫，一边和朋友们喝清酒一边大笑。莫拉莱斯侦探用无线电呼叫增援，更多警察很快赶到了现场。他们等到丹尼尔付了餐费，然后从餐厅后门进入并排队走进了宴会厅。
When Daniel looked up and saw them, all of the blood drained from his face. The detectives flashed their badges and patted Daniel down, before snapping a pair of handcuffs around his wrists. Then, he was escorted out of his own bachelor party and into a waiting police car. Once Daniel was seated in an interrogation room at Costa Mesa police station, he seemed more relaxed than he'd looked at the restaurant. Before questioning began, Daniel assured the interviewing detectives, I'm going to tell you everything, I'm sick of covering for Sam. He said he knew nothing about Julie Kibouishi's murder, but had been duped into helping supply funds for Sam Hare's escape. He also admitted that the man in the black baseball cap had never existed. He had invented him to cover up for himself.
当丹尼尔抬头看到他们时，他脸上的血色瞬间褪尽。侦探们亮出徽章，对丹尼尔进行搜身，然后把一副手铐“咔哒”一声铐在他的手腕上。随后，他被护送出自己的单身汉派对，带进了一辆等候的警车。一旦丹尼尔坐在科斯塔梅萨警察局的审讯室内，他似乎比在餐厅里时显得更加放松。在审问开始之前，丹尼尔向审讯侦探保证：“我会把一切都告诉你们，我厌倦了替萨姆打掩护。”他说他对朱莉·基博伊什的谋杀一无所知，但被愚弄去帮助为萨姆·黑尔的逃跑提供资金。他还承认那个戴黑色棒球帽的男子根本不存在。那是他编造出来为自己掩盖的。
Daniel explained that Sam had called him the previous Friday morning, hours before he later attacked and killed Julie Kibouishi. Sam had offered to pay Daniel if he helped him out with the scheme. He was planning to drain his own bank account using a third party, and then intended to file a claim that his debit card had been stolen. His bank would have to refund what had been taken, and he'd get double the payout. The author was tempting. Daniel and his fiancee Rachel had little money. The community theatre shows they loved performing paid nothing, and they both worked odd jobs to get by. Somehow, they'd wound up severely in debt and months behind on their rent. What Sam was suggesting was illegal, but Daniel desperately wanted some cash.
丹尼尔解释说，萨姆在前一天周五早上，也就是他袭击并杀死朱莉·基博伊什几小时前给他打过电话。萨姆提出如果丹尼尔帮他搞定这个计划就付钱给他。他正计划通过第三方掏空自己的银行账户，然后打算提出借记卡被盗的索赔。他的银行必须退还被拿走的钱，他就能得到双倍的赔付。这个提议很诱人。丹尼尔和他的未婚妻蕾切尔没什么钱。他们热爱的社区剧院演出没有薪水，两人都靠打零工维生。不知何故，他们最终负债累累，房租拖欠了好几个月。萨姆建议的事情是非法的，但丹尼尔迫切想要一些现金。
He agreed to participate, and Sam said he would stay clear of the ATMs being used to make withdrawals. That way, no one could say they had seen him there, and his face wouldn't be captured by the machine's cameras. Daniel asked his teenage friend Wesley, whom he'd met through their shared interest in theatre, to make the withdrawals. Daniel told Wesley he was working for a bail bonds agent, and that the card belonged to one of the agent's clients who had gone on the run after posting bail. He wanted Wesley's help to drain the client's account and had shown the teenager how to use the card and withdraw funds in $400 increments. He'd said it was vital that Wesley always wear a hat and sunglasses when he was at the ATM. Because Wesley was underage, Daniel believed he was less likely to get in trouble if he was caught. Daniel insisted that he had no idea where Sam Hare was now.
他同意参与，萨姆说他会避开用于提款的自动取款机。这样，没人会说在那里见过他，他的脸也不会被机器的摄像头捕捉到。丹尼尔请了他的少年朋友韦斯利（他通过对戏剧的共同兴趣认识了韦斯利）来取款。丹尼尔告诉韦斯利他在为保释金担保人工作，这张卡属于担保人的一个客户，该客户在交纳保释金后潜逃了。他想让韦斯利帮忙掏空客户的账户，并向这名少年展示了如何使用该卡并以400美元为增量提取资金。他说韦斯利在自动取款机前务必戴帽子和太阳镜，这一点至关重要。因为韦斯利未成年，丹尼尔相信如果被抓，他惹上麻烦的可能性较小。丹尼尔坚称他现在完全不知道萨姆·黑尔在哪里。
Setting the credit fraud story aside, the interrogators changed the subject back to Julie Kibuishi. Did Daniel know anything about her murder? After initially saying he didn't, Daniel admitted that he did. Sam had told him all about it. On the evening of Friday, May 21, Daniel and his fiancee Rachel had performed on stage in the community theatre musical they were both in, before returning home for a quiet night watching TV on the couch. The next morning, Daniel was woken by a steady knocking at his front door. He opened it and saw Sam Hare standing outside, looking nervous. When Daniel asked if everything was alright, Sam replied, Not good, we're in trouble.
抛开信用卡诈骗的故事不谈，审讯人员将话题转回了朱莉·基布伊什。丹尼尔知道关于她谋杀的任何事情吗？在最初表示不知道之后，丹尼尔承认他确实知道。萨姆把一切都告诉了他。在5月21日星期五的晚上，丹尼尔和他的未婚妻蕾切尔在他们俩都参加的社区剧院音乐剧中进行了舞台表演，然后回家在沙发上安静地看电视度过了一晚。第二天早上，丹尼尔被一阵急促的敲门声吵醒。他打开门，看到萨姆·黑尔站在外面，神情紧张。当丹尼尔问一切是否安好时，萨姆回答：“不太好，我们有麻烦了。”
Sam begged Daniel to get him out of Costa Mesa and handed over his laptop for safekeeping. Daniel told detectives where they could find the device in his apartment. The two got into Sam's white pondiac with Daniel behind the wheel. As they headed southbound down the Interstate 405 freeway, Sam suddenly made an admission. There's a body in my apartment. I shot somebody. I was not happy about it. It was a fit of rage and honestly, she had it coming. She, Daniel asked. Sam told him the victim was his good friend Julie Kibuishi. He had gotten drunk and high on ecstasy the night before and started scrolling through photos of Julie on social media.
萨姆恳求丹尼尔把他弄出科斯塔梅萨，并交出了他的笔记本电脑以妥善保管。丹尼尔告诉侦探他们可以在他公寓里的哪里找到这个设备。两人上了萨姆白色的庞蒂亚克，由丹尼尔开车。当他们向南开上405号州际高速公路时，萨姆突然坦白了。“我的公寓里有一具尸体。我枪杀了几个人。我对此并不高兴。这是一时冲动，老实说，她是咎由自取。”“她？”丹尼尔问。萨姆告诉他受害者是他的好朋友朱莉·基布伊什。他前一晚喝醉了并嗑了摇头丸，开始在社交媒体上浏览朱莉的照片。
Becoming upset as he looked at the images, he started texting Julie, asking her to come over. When she arrived at his apartment, he propositioned her and she refused, so he shot and killed her. Daniel was shocked. He knew Julie from their social circle at Camden Martinique. She often joined the gatherings there as a friend of Sam's and now Sam had made him a partial accessory to her murder by asking for his help. Daniel pulled off the highway and began to shout, What the fuck? What have you got me into? What are you doing? Sam ordered Daniel not to tell anyone and threatened. I know where you live. You wrap me out. I'm going to fucking kill you. And better yet, I'm going to start with your wife. The two struck a deal.
看着这些图像时他感到心烦意乱，于是开始给朱莉发短信，要求她过来。当她到达他的公寓时，他向她求欢而她拒绝了，于是他开枪杀死了她。丹尼尔大为震惊。他从卡姆登-马蒂尼克社交圈里认识朱莉。她经常作为萨姆的朋友加入那里的聚会，现在萨姆通过寻求他的帮助，让他成了她谋杀案的部分同谋。丹尼尔将车驶离高速公路并开始大喊：“他妈的这是怎么回事？你把我卷入了什么？你在干什么？”萨姆命令丹尼尔不准告诉任何人并威胁道：“我知道你住哪。你要是把我供出来，我他妈的就杀了你。更糟的是，我要从你老婆开始下手。”两人达成了一笔交易。
Sam would give Daniel the entire contents of one of his bank accounts, a sum that totaled $16,000 if Daniel would help him conceal his crime and escape. Daniel adamantly denied that he helped Sam in any other way aside from getting him cash and driving him out of town. When asked where exactly he had taken Sam, Daniel said he had dropped him off at the Los Altos shopping centre in Long Beach. Sam took off somewhere unknown, while Daniel drove Sam's car to a quiet street nearby and abandoned it. Investigators informed Daniel Wozniak that they needed one more thing from him, a DNA test, just so they could eliminate him as a suspect. Although Daniel was happy to oblige and allowed a detective to swab his mouth, he suddenly added another new detail to his story. He had been in Sam's apartment on the afternoon of Friday, May 21. He'd only gone in there briefly to use the bathroom, and he might have also quickly ducked out to the patio. If the detectives found his DNA in those locations, that was the reason why.
如果丹尼尔帮他隐瞒罪行并协助逃跑，萨姆将把他的一个银行账户的全部内容交给他，总计16000美元。丹尼尔坚决否认他在帮萨姆弄现金和开车送他出城之外有任何其他方面的协助。当被问及具体把萨姆带到了哪里时，丹尼尔说他把萨姆在长滩的洛斯阿拉托斯（Los Altos）购物中心放下。萨姆不知去向，而丹尼尔开着萨姆的车到附近一条安静的街道将其抛弃。调查人员通知丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克他们还需要他的一样东西——DNA测试，只是为了将他作为嫌疑人排除。虽然丹尼尔很乐意配合并允许侦探擦拭他的口腔，但他突然在故事中添加了一个新细节。他曾在5月21日星期五下午去过萨姆的公寓。他只是短暂地进去上个厕所，而且他可能还迅速溜去过露台。如果侦探在那些地方发现了他的DNA，这就是原因。
With Daniel now admitting to visiting Sam's apartment on the day of Julie Kibouishi's murder, the detectives began to push harder. Had he assisted Sam in cleaning up the crime scene? Was there a chance he had seen Julie's body? Did Sam tell him what he'd done with the murder weapon? Daniel answered no to every question, his tone growing louder and increasingly belligerent each time. Having cooperated with investigators every step of the way, Daniel seemed confident that he would be allowed to go home. He stood up, as did the detectives. But his latest admission meant he was now being charged with accessory to murder after the fact. When the detectives informed Daniel that he wouldn't be going anywhere, shock washed over his face. Suddenly growing panicked, he blurted out, I will talk to you about anything if it gets me to my wedding on Friday. That's what I will promise. He repeated his earlier claims, but continued to deny having seen Julie's body in Sam's apartment.
鉴于丹尼尔现在承认在朱莉·基博伊什被谋杀当天去过萨姆的公寓，侦探们开始加紧施压。他协助萨姆清理犯罪现场了吗？他有没有可能见过朱莉的尸体？萨姆有没有告诉他凶器怎么处理了？丹尼尔对每个问题都回答“不”，他的语气每一次都变得更大声、越来越好斗。由于在每一步都与调查人员合作，丹尼尔似乎确信自己会被允许回家。他站了起来，侦探们也是。但他最新的承认意味着他现在被指控为谋杀罪的窝藏包庇罪（事后从犯）。当侦探们通知丹尼尔他哪儿也去不了时，震惊写满了他的脸。突然变得惊慌失措的他脱口而出：“只要能让我去参加周五的婚礼，关于什么我都可以跟你们谈。我向他保证。”他重复了先前的说法，但继续否认在萨姆的公寓里见过朱莉的尸体。
The detectives kept pushing. Eventually, Daniel yelled in a dramatic and booming voice. I don't know what else you want me to say. I don't know. I don't know. He hovered his hand briefly in front of his face as though shaken, then anxiously began running it through his hair. One of the detectives calmly replied, Tell us the truth. You're not that good of an actor. After shaking his head for several moments, Daniel finally declared, Yes, I saw the goddamn body. Is that what you want to hear?
侦探们继续紧逼。最终，丹尼尔用一种戏剧化且低沉的声音大喊道：“我不知道你们还想让我说什么。我不知道。我不知道。”他的手短暂地在脸前晃了晃，仿佛受到惊吓，接着焦躁不安地开始把手插进头发里。其中一名侦探冷静地回答：“说实话吧。你没那么会演戏。”摇了了几下头后，丹尼尔终于宣称：“对，我看到了那具该死的尸体。这是你们想听的吗？”
He explained that Sam hadn't actually confessed to him in the car. Instead, he had told Daniel about the murder while they were still at Camden Martinique. Sam had asked him for help cleaning up the crime scene, so Daniel followed Sam to his apartment. Upon entering the bedroom, he saw Julie's body lying by the bed. Moving in for a closer look, he leaned over Julie and examined her. When asked, What did you see? Daniel replied, Saw two gunshots in her head. Daniel Wozniak was taken to a holding cell.
他解释说萨姆其实并没有在车里向他坦白。相反，他是在他们还在卡姆登-马蒂尼克时就把谋杀的事告诉了丹尼尔。萨姆曾请求他帮忙清理犯罪现场，于是丹尼尔跟着萨姆去了他的公寓。一进卧室，他就看到朱莉的尸体躺在床边。为了看清楚一点，他俯身越过朱莉并检查了她。当被问及“你看到了什么？”时，丹尼尔回答：“看到她头部有两处枪伤。”丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克被带到了一个临时拘留室。
Although he had hoped police would release him in time to attend his wedding, There was no way they were allowing an accessory to murder to walk free. By now, it was Thursday, May 27, and he'd been in custody since late the previous night. He was supposed to be getting married the following day. Inside his cell, Daniel had access to a telephone. He placed a call to his fiance, 22-year-old Rachel Buffett. Rachel hadn't had much sleep the night before. A detective had visited her at home to let her know Daniel was being interviewed
尽管他曾希望警察能及时放他去参加婚礼，但警方绝不可能让一个谋杀案的从犯逍遥法外。此时已经是5月27日星期四，他从前晚深夜起就被拘留了。他本该在第二天结婚。在牢房里，丹尼尔可以使用电话。他给未婚妻、22岁的蕾切尔·布菲打了个电话。蕾切尔前一晚没怎么睡。一名侦探曾去她家拜访，让她知道丹尼尔正在接受讯问，
and asked her to answer some questions as well. Rachel agreed to accompany him to the station and was released within a couple of hours. Realising how serious the situation was, she had driven to her parents' house to let them know that the wedding wouldn't be going ahead. Then she paid her future in-laws a visit informing them that Daniel had been arrested. When her cell phone rang a little while later, she had pulled in at a gas station. Hi baby, Daniel greeted her in a flat voice. When Rachel demanded to know what he had done, Daniel explained how he had helped Sam cover some stuff up.
并要求她也回答一些问题。蕾切尔同意陪他去警局，并在两小时内获释。意识到情况的严重性，她开车去了父母家，告诉他们婚礼不会举行了。然后她拜访了未婚夫的父母，通知他们丹尼尔被捕了。不久后她的手机响了，她把车停在了一家加油站。“嗨，宝贝，”丹尼尔用平淡的声音向她打招呼。当蕾切尔要求知道他做了什么时，丹尼尔解释了他如何帮萨姆掩盖一些事情。
He said he had also helped Sam acquire some, quote, hardcore ecstasy which Sam had been high on when he murdered Julie. Daniel knew his actions were wrong but said they needed the money. Rachel reprimanded Daniel, telling him, we never need money, we need to be good people and to just have each other. Then she added something else. Rachel mentioned how she had spoken to Daniel's older brother, Tim Wozniak, that morning. She'd bumped into him when she was leaving Daniel's parents' house
他说他还帮萨姆获得了一些，引述，“强力摇头丸”，萨姆在谋杀朱莉时正处于兴奋状态。丹尼尔知道他的行为是错的，但说他们需要钱。蕾切尔训斥了丹尼尔，告诉他：“我们从来不需要钱，我们需要做个好人，并且彼此拥有。”然后她补充了另一件事。蕾切尔提到她那天早上是如何跟丹尼尔的哥哥蒂姆·沃兹尼亚克（Tim Wozniak）交谈的。她离开丹尼尔父母家时碰到了他，
and told him how Daniel had been arrested. Upon hearing this, Tim seemed agitated and started fiddling with his cell phone. He blurted out something about having evidence. Realizing the significance of this statement, Rachel told Daniel that she was planning to report it to the detectives investigating the case as soon as possible. Daniel was silent for a moment before stating, then, I'm doomed. At midday, one of the detectives who had spent the previous night grilling Daniel Wozniak received a phone call.
并告诉他丹尼尔是如何被捕的。听到这个消息，蒂姆显得很激动，开始摆弄他的手机。他脱口说出了有些证据的话。意识到这句话的重要性，蕾切尔告诉丹尼尔她打算尽快向调查该案的侦探报告此事。丹尼尔沉默了一会儿，然后说：“那我完了。”中午时分，前一天晚上盘问丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克的一名侦探接到了一个电话。
It was from the jailer who was currently watching over Daniel in custody. Apparently, Daniel wanted to speak with investigators again. The detective made his way to the holding cell where Daniel Wozniak was being held. Daniel looked distraught and nervous. He had draped a blanket over his head and shoulders, which added to his bereft appearance. Without hesitation, he told the detective, I need to talk to you about something. Once again, Daniel was escorted to an interrogation room where he was read his rights,
电话是目前在拘留所看守丹尼尔的看守打来的。显然，丹尼尔想再次与调查人员谈谈。侦探来到了关押丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克的临时拘留室。丹尼尔看起来心烦意乱且紧张。他在头上和肩膀上披了一条毯子，这让他显得更加凄惨。他毫不犹豫地对侦探说：“我有些事需要跟你们谈谈。”再次，丹尼尔被护送到审讯室，在那里向他宣读了权利，
but this time he waived them. Staring directly at the detective, Daniel said, I'm crazy, and I did it. Almost two weeks earlier, Daniel was arrested. Daniel was arrested. Daniel was arrested. Daniel was arrested.
但这次他放弃了这些权利。丹尼尔直盯着侦探说：“我疯了，是我干的。”近两周前，丹尼尔被捕了。丹尼尔被捕了。丹尼尔被捕了。丹尼尔被捕了。
Daniel was arrested. Almost two weeks earlier on Saturday, May 15, Daniel Wozniak had been arrested in Costa Mesa for driving while under the influence. He was booked at Orange County Jail where he placed some phone calls to friends, trying to source funds so he could be released on bail. Money was an issue for Daniel. He had two bank accounts, both of which were overdrawn, and owed a couple of months' rent to his and Rachel's landlord.
丹尼尔被捕了。大约两周前的5月15日星期六，丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克（Daniel Wozniak）在科斯塔梅萨因酒后驾车被捕。他被关押在奥兰治县监狱，在那里他给朋友们打了几个电话，试图筹集保释金以便获释。钱对丹尼尔来说是个问题。他有两个银行账户，都透支了，还欠他和蕾切尔的房东几个月的房租。
Now, he was only going to be in more trouble, with bail required and a criminal charged to defend. One of Daniel's friends tried to help him find the cash by phoning other acquaintances who might be willing to contribute some bail money. He got in touch with Daniel's neighbour, Sam Hare, and asked if he'd be willing to assist. Sam refused. Although he had about $62,000 thanks to his meticulous saving of his combat pay, he wasn't that close to Daniel and didn't want to get mixed up in his criminal charges. Daniel had to spend a night in custody but managed to scrape together enough to pay his bail
现在，他只会陷入更多的麻烦中，需要支付保释金，还有刑事指控要应付。丹尼尔的一个朋友试图通过给其他可能愿意出资保释的熟人打电话来帮他筹集现金。他联系了丹尼尔的邻居萨姆·黑尔（Sam Hare），问他是否愿意帮忙。萨姆拒绝了。尽管他靠着一丝不苟地积攒战斗津贴攒下了大约6.2万美元，但他和丹尼尔并不那么亲密，也不想卷入他的刑事指控中。丹尼尔不得不被拘留了一晚，但设法勉强凑够了保释金
and was released the next day. That one night behind bars had been enough, he subsequently told his friends. He never wanted to go back there again. When he bumped into Sam Hare at one of Camden Martinique's jacuzzis, he shared his experience with him, complaining about how awful jail had been. Sam was incredulous. He had spent more than a year in LA County men's jail while awaiting trial for murder when he was 18 years old. One night was nothing.
并在第二天获释。他后来告诉朋友，那段在铁窗后面的夜晚已经足够了。他再也不想回到那种地方去了。当他在卡姆登·马蒂尼克（Camden Martinique）的一个按摩浴缸里偶遇萨姆·黑尔时，他与对方分享了自己的经历，抱怨监狱有多糟糕。萨姆对此表示怀疑。在他18岁时，因涉嫌谋杀候审，他曾在洛杉矶县男子监狱待了一年多。一个晚上根本不算什么。
I know all about being in jail, he told Daniel, before explaining how he had been charged in relation to a friend's homicide. It was the first Daniel had heard about Sam's past before he became a soldier and college student. Around the same time, Sam learned that Daniel and Rachel were behind on their rent and facing eviction. He offered to help pay what they owed. Although he didn't want to be responsible for Daniel's bail money, rent was a different matter. He took Daniel to a nearby ATM to withdraw some cash. As he punched in his pin number and his account's total balance flashed on the screen, Daniel watched closely.
“我对监狱里的情况了如指掌，”他告诉丹尼尔，接着解释了他如何因涉嫌参与朋友的谋杀案而被指控。这是丹尼尔在得知萨姆成为军人和大学生之前的过去后，第一次听到这件事。大约在同一时间，萨姆得知丹尼尔和蕾切尔房租拖欠并面临驱赶。他主动提出帮他们支付所欠房租。尽管他不想为丹尼尔的保释金负责，但房租是另一回事。他带丹尼尔去附近的自动取款机取了一些现金。当萨姆输入密码，屏幕上闪过他账户的总余额时，丹尼尔仔细地看着。
The Southern California city of Los Alamitos is home to the Joint Forces Training Base, a military facility that has featured in Hollywood films over the years. Its proximity to the center of American filmmaking has made a convenient backdrop for military-themed movies. In 1942, the base opened the Liberty Theater, where shows were staged and films were screened for servicemen and women. Daniel Wozniak was well acquainted with the Liberty Theater. It was close to his family's home in Long Beach, and he had performed on its stage multiple times. He struck the theater owners as a charismatic and cheerful person who loved to tell jokes and be the center of attention. It was at the Liberty where Daniel struck up a rapport with younger cast member Wesley and became something of a mentor to the teenager.
南加州城市洛斯阿拉米托斯（Los Alamitos）是联合部队训练基地（Joint Forces Training Base）的所在地，这是一个多年来曾在好莱坞电影中亮相的军事设施。它靠近美国电影制作中心的地理位置，使其成为军事主题电影的便捷背景。1942年，该基地开设了自由剧院（Liberty Theater），在那里为军人举办演出并放映电影。丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克对自由剧院非常熟悉。它离他家人在长滩的家很近，他曾多次在该剧院的舞台上表演。剧院老板觉得他是一个富有魅力、开朗的人，喜欢讲笑话并成为人们关注的焦点。正是在自由剧院，丹尼尔与年轻的演员韦斯利（Wesley）建立了良好的关系，并成为了这个十几岁少年的导师。
On the morning of Friday, May 21, 2010, Daniel asked his neighbor Sam Hare to help him with something. He needed a hand moving some items that were stored at the Liberty Theater. Sam was all too happy to assist. When his mother called him at 12.25pm that day, he mentioned how he was in the middle of helping someone out and would call her back soon. He never did. Daniel and Sam drove to the theater in Sam's car. Once there, they headed backstage and towards a ladder that led upstairs to a small attic where the theater's lights were. The two men climbed to the ladder and Daniel directed Sam towards a piece of furniture stating,
2010年5月21日星期五上午，丹尼尔请邻居萨姆·黑尔帮他一个忙。他需要人帮忙搬运一些存放在自由剧院的东西。萨姆非常乐意帮忙。当天中午12点25分，当他的母亲打电话给他时，他提到自己正在帮别人一个忙，待会儿会回电话给她。但他再也没有打过。丹尼尔和萨姆开着萨姆的车去了剧院。到了那里，他们走到后台，朝着一架梯子走去，梯子通往剧院灯光所在的小阁楼。两名男子爬上梯子，丹尼尔指引萨姆走到一件家具前，说道：
I need you to help me move this. Sam began to lift the item. As Sam knelt with his back to him, Daniel pulled out a .38 caliber semi-automatic pistol that he had previously stolen from his parents' house. Daniel aimed the gun at Sam and pulled the trigger, shooting Sam in the back of the head. Sam fell to the floor, shocked and confused. Looking up at Daniel, he said, I need help, something hit me. It felt like an electric shock. Daniel pulled the trigger again, but the pistol jammed. He ejected the stuck round, reloaded the weapon and, with Sam still staring at him, he shot him once more in the temple.
“我需要你帮我搬这个。”萨姆开始搬起这件物品。正当萨姆背对着他跪着时，丹尼尔掏出一把.38口径半自动手枪，这把枪是他以前从父母家里偷来的。丹尼尔用枪瞄准萨姆并扣动了扳机，击中了萨姆的后脑勺。萨姆震惊而困惑地倒在地上。他抬头看着丹尼尔说：“我需要帮助，有什么东西击中了我和。感觉像触电一样。”丹尼尔再次扣动扳机，但手枪卡壳了。他退掉了卡住的子弹，重新装弹，在萨姆依然盯着他的情况下，又朝着他的太阳穴开了一枪。
After killing Sam, Daniel grabbed his victims' belongings including his keys, bank cards and cell phone. Then he went back home, leaving Sam's body in the attic of the Liberty Theater. That evening, he headed to a different theater where he was the lead in a production of the musical Nine. His fiancee Rachel co-starred alongside him. One reviewer had previously described Daniel's performance as the best thing about the show, but that night he seemed slightly less polished than usual. Sometimes he paused before delivering lines, causing other cast and crew members to worry that he might have forgotten them. While backstage, Daniel used Sam's cell phone to text Julie Kibouishi. Pretending to be Sam, he wrote, Can you come over tonight at midnight alone? Very upset. Need to talk.
杀害萨姆后，丹尼尔拿走了受害者的财物，包括他的钥匙、银行卡和手机。然后他回到了家，把萨姆的尸体留在了自由剧院的阁楼里。那天晚上，他前往另一家剧院，在那里他是音乐剧《九》（Nine）的主演。他的未婚妻蕾切尔与他同台主演。一位评论员此前曾将丹尼尔的演出描述为该剧中最棒的部分，但那天晚上他看起来似乎比平时略显生疏。有时他在台词前会停顿，导致其他演员和工作人员担心他是否把台词忘了。在后台时，丹尼尔用萨姆的手机给久保石茱莉（Julie Kibouishi）发了短信。他假装是萨姆，写道：“今晚你能一个人过来吗？我很沮丧。我们需要谈谈。”
Seemingly wanting to reassure Julie that Sam's motivations were pure, he twice clarified that he wasn't asking her over to have sex. Julie, who was replying in between having a meal with her brother and his fiance, seemed to find this suggestion absurd, writing, LOL, Sam, we are like brother and sis. No sex. She agreed to come over to Sam's apartment at midnight by herself. After the performance concluded, Daniel headed home and waited. Sitting on the couch with his fiancee Rachel, he watched a film and then some lighthearted television. At close to midnight, he tucked a blanket over Rachel, who was dozing, snuck out of their apartment and headed upstairs to Sam's. He claims he was standing outside the front door when Julie Kibouishi arrived, concerned about her seemingly distraught friend. Daniel explained that he was worried too. Sam had just called him upset and said he was going through some stuff.
似乎为了让茱莉确信萨姆的动机很纯洁，他两次澄清说他不是叫她过来发生性关系的。茱莉在和哥哥及其未婚妻吃顿饭的间隙回了短信，似乎觉得这个建议荒谬绝伦，写道：“哈哈，萨姆，我们就像兄妹一样。没有性关系。”她同意午夜独自一人去萨姆的公寓。演出结束后，丹尼尔回到家等待着。他和未婚妻蕾切尔坐在沙发上，看了一部电影，然后看了一些轻松的电视节目。接近午夜时，他给正在打瞌睡的蕾切尔盖上一条毯子，偷偷溜出公寓，上楼去了萨姆家。他声称当茱莉·久保石到达时，他正站在前门外，对方正为她看似心烦意乱的朋友感到担心。丹尼尔解释说他也很担心。萨姆刚打电话给他，说他心情不好，正经历一些事情。
Me too, said Julie. Daniel told her he had a spare key and suggested they go in to Sam's apartment together to check he was alright. The two walked inside. Daniel directed Julie to Sam's bedroom, asking, oh by the way, did you see this in Sam's bed? As Julie leaned over to see what Daniel was talking about, he pulled out the pistol and shot her in the back of the head, just as he had done with Sam. After firing twice, Daniel posed Julie's lifeless body by ripping her jeans and scribbling a crude message on her back. He wanted it to look as though there had been a sexual assault. The following morning, Daniel headed back to the Liberty Theatre where Sam's body still lay in the attic.
“我也是，”茱莉说。丹尼尔告诉她他有一把备用钥匙，并建议他们一起进萨姆的公寓去看看他是否安好。两人走了进去。丹尼尔将茱莉引导至萨姆的卧室，问道：“哦，对了，你在萨姆的床上看到这个了吗？”正当茱莉俯身去看丹尼尔在说什么时，他掏出手枪，击中了她的后脑勺，就像他对萨姆做的那样。开了两枪后，丹尼尔摆弄茱莉毫无生气的尸体，撕破了她的牛仔裤，并在她背上潦草地写下一条粗俗的信息。他想让现场看起来像是发生了一起性侵案。第二天早上，丹尼尔回到自由剧院，萨姆的尸体依然躺在阁楼里。
He cut Sam's clothes off with a pair of scissors. Then, using a saw and hatchet that he had borrowed from his fiance's brother, Daniel removed Sam's head, one of his hands, and one of his forearms, which was tattooed. Daniel hoped that removing these body parts would prevent the remains from being identified. As he dismembered his former friend, Daniel began to laugh aloud to himself. He couldn't quite believe what he was doing. Interviewing detectives were unsurprised by Daniel Wozniak's chilling confession. They had long suspected his involvement in Julie's murder went far beyond what he'd originally claimed, and they weren't the only ones. Steve Hare, Sam's father, had started to wonder about Daniel when he began looking into his son's disappearance on his own.
他用一把剪刀剪掉了萨姆的衣服。然后，利用从他未婚妻的兄弟那里借来的锯子和短斧，丹尼尔切下了萨姆的头、一只手和一只纹有纹理的前臂。丹尼尔希望移除这些身体部位可以防止遗体被识别。在肢解他以前的朋友时，丹尼尔开始自顾自地大笑起来。他简直不敢相信自己在做什么。负责审讯的侦探对丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克令人不寒栗的供词并不感到惊讶。他们早就怀疑他参与茱莉谋杀案的程度远远超出了他最初的说法，而且他们并非唯一这么想的人。萨姆的父亲史蒂夫·黑尔（Steve Hare）在开始独自调查儿子的失踪事件时，就已经开始对丹尼尔产生怀疑了。
Another friend of Sam's had given Steve Daniel's contact details so he could ask whether he had seen his son. Steve noticed that Daniel's phone number had a Long Beach area code, the same neighborhood where withdrawals were being made from Sam's bank account. When Steve checked the numbers of Sam's other friends, he realized that Daniel was the only one with the connection to Long Beach. Daniel had further provoked Steve's suspicions during a conversation they had over the phone. When Steve asked if Daniel knew of anything that had been troubling Sam, Daniel replied that he'd mentioned having some girl problems, as well as some family issues. The latter raised a huge red flag for Steve. He and his wife Raquel were extremely close to their only child, and Sam had no family problems to speak of. Steve shared his suspicions with investigators, who'd also noticed some strange details surrounding Julie's murder and Sam's disappearance.
萨姆的另一个朋友给了史蒂夫丹尼尔的联系方式，以便他可以询问他是否见过自己的儿子。史蒂夫注意到丹尼尔的电话号码带有长滩地区的区号，这与萨姆银行账户被取款的街区是同一个。当史蒂夫核对萨姆其他朋友的号码时，他意识到丹尼尔是唯一一个与长滩有联系的人。在一通电话交谈中，丹尼尔进一步加深了史蒂夫的怀疑。当史蒂夫询问丹尼尔是否知道有什么事情在困扰萨姆时，丹尼尔回答说他曾提到有一些关于女孩的问题，以及一些家庭问题。后者给史蒂夫敲响了巨大的警钟。他和妻子拉奎尔（Raquel）与他们唯一的孩子极其亲密，而萨姆根本没有什么家庭问题可言。史蒂夫将他的怀疑分享给了调查人员，他们也注意到了围绕茱莉谋杀案和萨姆失踪案的一些奇怪细节。
Although the crime scene suggested Julie had been raped and her killing was sexually motivated, her autopsy revealed no evidence of a sexual assault. Moreover, there was nothing to suggest that Sam had ever harbored romantic feelings for Julie, or that the two were anything other than close friends. Once the withdrawals from Sam's bank account were definitively linked to Daniel Wozniak, it looked as though Steve's hair's instincts had been correct. Throughout their lengthy questioning of Daniel in the early stages of their investigation, detectives were struck by the way his story kept changing. Their growing suspicions were cemented during a pivotal moment in the interrogation, when Daniel described seeing Julie's murdered body in Sam's apartment. In an attempt to coax information from him, the detectives had lied, telling him that the results of his DNA swab were back already. His genetic material was found on Julie's body. Trying to explain this away, Daniel detailed how he had leaned over Julie while in Sam's apartment. Perhaps his DNA had fallen onto her.
尽管犯罪现场表明茱莉曾遭到强奸，且其被害具有性动机，但她的尸检并未显示任何性侵犯的证据。此外，没有任何迹象表明萨姆曾对茱莉怀有浪漫情感，或者两人除了亲密朋友之外还有其他关系。一旦萨姆银行账户的取款记录明确与丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克联系在一起，史蒂夫·黑尔的直觉似乎就是正确的。在调查初期对丹尼尔进行的漫长审讯中，侦探们对他的说辞不断改变这一事实感到震惊。在审讯的一个关键时刻，当丹尼尔描述在萨姆的公寓里看到茱莉被谋杀的尸体时，他们日益增长的怀疑得到了证实。为了从中套取信息，侦探们撒了谎，告诉他他的DNA拭纸结果已经出来了。在茱莉的尸体上发现了他的遗传物质。为了掩饰这一点，丹尼尔详细描述了自己在萨姆的公寓里时是如何俯身越过茱莉的。也许他的DNA落在了她身上。
When asked to describe what he saw when he looked at Julie, Daniel said there were two gunshot wounds in her head, but only one wound was visible. Steve's hair and even the seasoned investigators who had attended the crime scene all thought that Julie was shot once, until her autopsy result came through. It was only possible for Daniel to know she had been shot twice, if he was somehow involved in her murder. Daniel had only killed Julie to cover up his true target, Sam. His hope was that Sam would be blamed for Julie's murder. To Daniel's thinking, Sam's previous criminal charge would make him a plausible suspect in another violent attack. Hopefully investigators would assume he raped and killed Julie, then escaped to live on the run. Daniel had known his fate was sealed when his fiancee Rachel told him she intended to tell the police about evidence his brother had.
当被要求描述他看到茱莉时的情景时，丹尼尔说她的头部有两处枪伤，但当时只能看到一处伤口。史蒂夫·黑尔甚至是参加过犯罪现场调查的经验丰富的调查人员，都认为茱莉只中了一枪，直到她的尸检结果出来。丹尼尔只有在某种程度上参与了她的谋杀，才可能知道她中了两枪。丹尼尔杀死茱莉只是为了掩盖他的真正目标——萨姆。他希望萨姆会被指控谋杀茱莉。在丹尼尔看来，萨姆先前的刑事指控将使他在另一起暴力袭击中成为一个合乎情理的嫌疑人。希望调查人员会认为他强奸并杀害了茱莉，然后逃跑过上了潜逃的生活。当未婚妻蕾切尔告诉他她打算向警方透露他哥哥持有的证据时，丹尼尔知道自己的命运已经注定了。
After killing Julie and Sam, Daniel had given his brother Tim a box, telling him firmly not to open it. Inside was a backpack containing money Daniel had stolen from Sam's apartment, the pistol used to kill both victims, shell casings, Sam's passport and bloody clothing, and the tools Daniel had used to cut up his body. Supposedly, Tim had looked inside the box despite Daniel's strict instructions and subsequently called Daniel to ask about the items. Daniel knew that if the police learned about that evidence, then he was doomed. When investigators asked Daniel what his motivation for the grisly double homicide had been, he replied, money and insanity. Then he gave a strange, high-pitched laugh. Daniel knew that Sam had a significant amount of money and he wanted to get his hands on it. He explained that he was a pathological liar who couldn't bear to tell his fiancee Rachel that he was broke and they were about to be evicted.
在杀死茱莉和萨姆后，丹尼尔给了他的弟弟蒂姆（Tim）一个箱子，并坚定地告诉他不要打开。里面是一个背包，装有丹尼尔从萨姆公寓偷来的钱、用于杀害两名受害者的手枪、弹壳、萨姆的护照、血衣，以及丹尼尔用来分尸的工具。据推测，尽管丹尼尔有严格的指示，蒂姆还是打开了箱子查看，随后打电话给丹尼尔询问这些物品的事。丹尼尔知道，如果警方得知这些证据，那他就死定了。当调查人员询问丹尼尔这起骇人听闻的双重谋杀案的动机是什么时，他回答说：“金钱和疯狂。”然后他发出了一声奇怪而尖锐的笑声。丹尼尔知道萨姆有一大笔钱，他想把手伸向它。他解释说，他是一个病态的说谎者，无法忍受告诉未婚妻蕾切尔他破产了，他们即将被赶出住所。
He had also wanted to give her the honeymoon of her dreams. Rachel's parents were paying for the wedding, but Daniel wanted to take her on a cruise afterwards. Sure enough, when investigators checked Daniel's computer, they found internet searches for resorts in Mexico. He had also googled how to hide a body and quick ways to kill people. Detectives found Sam's hair's body in the attic of the Liberty Theatre. As Daniel Wozniak had described, he was missing his head and portions of both arms, but he was identifiable by a large tattoo on his chest that Daniel had apparently missed. It depicted a large love heart surrounded by roses, with the words mum and dad inked across the centre. After Daniel dismembered Sam's hair's body, he had placed his head, arm and hand in plastic bags.
他还想给她一个梦想中的蜜月。蕾切尔的父母正在支付婚礼费用，但丹尼尔想带她去乘游轮。果不其然，当调查人员检查丹尼尔的电脑时，他们发现了对墨西哥度假胜地的互联网搜索。他还用谷歌搜索了如何藏匿尸体以及快速杀人的方法。侦探在自由剧院的阁楼里找到了萨姆·黑尔的尸体。正如丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克所描述的那样，他的头部和两只手臂的一部分不见了，但可以通过他胸前的一个大纹身来识别，这个纹身丹尼尔显然漏掉了。它描绘了一个被玫瑰包围的大爱心，中间印着“爸爸妈妈”的字样。在丹尼尔肢解了萨姆·黑尔的尸体后，他将他的头、手臂和手放进了塑料袋里。
Then he stashed those bags in a backpack belonging to Sam. Daniel told investigators that on Saturday, May 22, while Sam and Julie's families were trying to locate them, he had driven to the El Dorado Nature Centre, a 105-acre park in Long Beach. He dug shallow holes in several locations, then placed the plastic bags containing Sam's body parts in separate holes. Daniel covered each one with loose dirt and leaves before leaving to get ready for a social event he was attending that night. The musical he was starring in was wrapping up the next day, so the cast were all celebrating with a party. Search teams headed out to the El Dorado Nature Centre on Friday, May 28. The park was split up into quadrants with each team covering a different area. By the end of the day, police had recovered Sam's forearm and hand.
然后，他将这些袋子藏在一个属于萨姆的背包里。丹尼尔告诉调查人员，在5月22日星期六，当萨姆和茱莉的家人们试图寻找他们时，他开车去了埃尔多拉多自然中心（El Dorado Nature Centre），那是长滩一个占地105英亩的公园。他在几个地方挖了浅坑，然后把装着萨姆尸体部分的塑料袋分别放进不同的坑里。丹尼尔用松散的泥土和树叶覆盖每一个坑，然后离开去准备他那天晚上要参加的社交活动。他主演的音乐剧第二天就要落幕了，所以演员们都在开派对庆祝。搜寻队于5月28日星期五前往埃尔多拉多自然中心。公园被划分为四个象限，每个队伍负责不同的区域。到一天结束时，警方找回了萨姆的前臂和手。
The following day, Saturday, May 29, would have been Sam's 27th birthday. On what should have been a day of celebration, his father Steve found himself in the position of having to pray that his son's head, the final piece of his body, would be found and brought home for burial. Steve's prayer was answered, with searchers locating Sam's head before the day was out. Steve and his wife Raquel had never believed for a moment that their son had killed Julie Kibouishi. From the beginning, they had been certain that he was the victim of a crime, not a perpetrator. Although Steve already suspected his son was dead, having his worst fear confirmed was devastating. He later told Keith Elliott Greenberg, author of the book Killing for You, that he was haunted by Daniel Wozniak's motivation for killing his son and Julie. Quote, I cannot believe that somebody would do something like this to a young man and a young woman just for a few thousand dollars.
第二天，即5月29日星期六，本应是萨姆的27岁生日。在这个本该充满庆祝的日子里，他的父亲史蒂夫却发现自己处在不得不祈祷的境地：祈祷他儿子的头部——他身体的最后一部分——能被找到并带回家安葬。史蒂夫的祈祷得到了回应，搜寻人员在这一天结束前找到了萨姆的头部。史蒂夫和他的妻子拉奎尔从未有一刻相信他们的儿子杀害了久保石茱莉。从一开始，他们就坚信他是犯罪的受害者，而不是加害者。尽管史蒂夫已经怀疑他的儿子死了，但当他最可怕的恐惧得到证实合时，他还是感到毁灭性的打击。他后来告诉《为你杀戮》（Killing for You）一书的作者基思·埃利奥特·格林伯格（Keith Elliott Greenberg），他一直被丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克杀死他儿子和茱莉的动机所困扰。他说：“我不敢相信有人会对一个年轻男子和一个年轻女子做出这样的事情，仅仅是为了几千美元。”
My boy is gone and I'm thinking, what a waste, what a waste. He saved all his money so he could buy a house, go to college and get married, and this guy takes it all away. Julie Kibouishi's family found themselves reliving the last night of her life over and over, thinking of how things might have been different. Julie's brother, Taka, wished he'd poured her more alcohol during dinner so she would have gotten drunk and had to stay over at his place. Her mother, Junco, had given Julie advice about avoiding traffic while heading out to Long Beach, not realizing that she was in danger of anything else that night. Friday, May 28, 2010, was supposed to be the day of Daniel Wozniak's wedding. Sam Hare had been an intended guest, with detectives finding an invitation typed in elegant font amongst the male in his apartment. Instead, Daniel was charged with two counts of first-degree murder for killing Sam and Julie.
“我的孩子没了，我在想，这是多么大的浪费，多么大的浪费。他省下所有的钱是为了买房子、上大学和结婚，而这个家伙把这一切都夺走了。”久保石茱莉的家人发现自己一次又一次地回味着她生命的最后一晚，思考着事情本可以如何不同。茱莉的哥哥塔卡（Taka）希望他在晚餐时给她倒更多的酒，这样她就会喝醉，不得不留宿在他家。她的母亲纯子（Junco）曾给茱莉提出过避开前往长滩时交通拥堵的建议，却没有意识到那天晚上她还面临着其他任何危险。2010年5月28日星期五，本应是丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克结婚的日子。萨姆·黑尔本应是受邀宾客，侦探在他的公寓信件中发现了一封用优雅字体打印的请柬。相反，丹尼尔因杀害萨姆和茱莉而被控两项一级谋杀罪。
He attempted to take his own life shortly after confessing to the crimes, and was taken to hospital, where he made a recovery. Police recovered the evidence that Daniel had given to his brother Tim for safekeeping, and Tim was charged with being an accessory to murder after the fact. Despite Daniel Wozniak's confession, he intended to plead not guilty. It was expected that he wouldn't face trial for at least a couple of years while the prosecution put their case together, but the process ended up taking more than five years. The prosecution team had decided the crimes warranted a death sentence, which contributed to further delays as the defense sought to have that option removed from the table. The prosecution ultimately prevailed. Daniel Wozniak's trial would proceed as a death penalty case. The trial finally began on December 9, 2015. The prosecution informed the jury how Sam Hare and Julie Kibuishi had been brutally killed due to Daniel Wozniak's desire for financial gain. They relied heavily on video recordings of Daniel's confession, and also caught upon several witnesses.
他在对罪行供认不讳后不久试图自杀，被送往医院后康复。警方找回了丹尼尔交给他的弟弟蒂姆代为保管的证据，蒂姆被指控为谋杀后的从犯。尽管丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克供认不讳，但他打算做无罪抗辩。预计在控方整理案卷期间，他至少几年内不会面临审判，但这一过程最终花费了五年多的时间。检察官团队认为这些罪行理应判处死刑，这导致了进一步的延误，因为辩方试图将这一选项排除在外。控方最终占了上风。丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克的审判将作为死刑案件进行。审判终于在2015年12月9日开始。控方向陪审团通报了萨姆·黑尔和久保石茱莉是如何由于丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克对金钱的渴望而被残酷杀害的。他们严重依赖丹尼尔供词的录像，并传唤了几位证人。
One of these was Sam Hare's father, Steve, who had to describe to the court how he had gone to his son's apartment to check on him, only to discover Julie Kibuishi's murdered body inside. Prosecutor Matt Murphy said the double homicide was, as ruthless as a murder gets, it's as cold-blooded as a murder gets, it's as unnecessary as a murder gets. The defense had no opening argument and called no witnesses to the stand. Within five days, the jury had retired to consider their verdict. It didn't take long. For two counts of murder in the first degree, they found Daniel Wozniak guilty. They also had to carefully consider his sentencing. Death penalty cases were rare in Orange County, only being sought by prosecutors in about 4% of eligible cases. The defense insisted that their client wasn't the worst kind of murderer and deserved a chance for redemption.
其中一位是萨姆·黑尔的父亲史蒂夫，他不得不向法庭描述他是如何去儿子的公寓查看他的情况，却发现久保石茱莉被谋杀的尸体躺在里面。检察官马特·墨菲（Matt Murphy）说，这起双重谋杀案“正如谋杀一样冷酷无情，正如谋杀一样毫无必要”。辩方没有做开场陈述，也没有传唤任何证人出庭。在五天内，陪审团退庭审议他们的裁决。这并没有花太长时间。对于两项一级谋杀罪，他们裁定丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克有罪。他们还必须仔细考虑他的量刑。死刑案件在奥兰治县很少见，检察官仅在约4%的符合条件的案件中寻求死刑。辩方坚称他们的当事人并非最坏的杀人犯，理应获得赎罪的机会。
But the prosecution argued that if ever a killer deserved the death penalty, Daniel Wozniak did, because he had treated his victims, quote, like trash. Addressing the jury directly, Matt Murphy asked, are they? Sam and Julie's parents also spoke in favor of a death sentence and shared deeply personal memories of their children with the court. After deliberating on the matter for more than an hour, the jury came to a unanimous decision. Daniel Wozniak would be sentenced to death. The heirs and the kibuwishis were given an opportunity to address him directly. When it came time for Junco Kibuwishi to speak, she asked her daughter's killer a question that had haunted her ever since she had learned that Julie had been used as a prop in Daniel Wozniak's scheme. Quote, you took her precious life and then you disgraced her. Why? What did she do to you?
但控方辩称，如果有什么杀人犯理应被判处死刑，那就是丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克，因为他对待受害者“就像垃圾一样”。马特·墨菲直接向陪审团喊道：“他们是吗？”萨姆和茱莉的父母也发言支持死刑，并与法庭分享了关于他们孩子的极其私密的记忆。经过一个多小时的审议，陪审团做出了一致决定。丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克将被判处死刑。黑尔和久保石一家获得了直接对他说话的机会。轮到久保石纯子（Junco Kibuwishi）发言时，她问了她女儿的凶手一个一直困扰着她的问题，自从她得知茱莉被当成丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克阴谋中的道具以来，这个问题就一直萦绕在她心头。她说：“你夺走了她宝贵的生命，然后你羞辱了她。为什么？她对你做了什么？”
How could you do anything like that to my baby? Reading his victim impact statement aloud, Steve Hare said, You Dan are a coward and a poster boy for the need for an effective death penalty in California. My only regret is that this state won't let me kill this coward myself. Although Daniel Wozniak was the only individual convicted of killing Sam Hare and Julie Kibuwishi, investigators and the victim's families were certain he hadn't acted entirely alone. Both Daniel's brother Tim and his fiancee Rachel Buffett were charged with being accessories to murder after the fact, but some were convinced that their involvement with the crimes went above and beyond that. Like Daniel, Rachel Buffett was an aspiring actor who performed in community theater productions. To earn money, she'd played the part of Ariel from The Little Mermaid at the Disneyland theme park in Anaheim. Rachel's small frame and wide blue eyes meant she was perfectly suited for the role of a Disney princess. But those who were close to the couple hadn't seen it as a fairytale romance. They claimed that Daniel had changed after meeting Rachel.
“你怎么能对我的宝贝做出那样的事？”史蒂夫·黑尔大声宣读他的受害者影响陈述时说道：“丹，你是个懦夫，是加州需要有效死刑的典型代表。我唯一的遗憾是这个州不让我自己杀了这个懦夫。”尽管丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克是被判谋杀萨姆·黑尔和久保石茱莉的唯一个人，但调查人员和受害者家属坚信他并非完全独自作案。丹尼尔的弟弟蒂姆和他的未婚妻蕾切尔·巴菲特（Rachel Buffett）都被指控为谋杀后的从犯，但有些人确信他们对这些罪行的参与远不止于此。与丹尼尔一样，蕾切尔·巴菲特也是一名有抱负的演员，在社区剧院制作中表演。为了赚钱，她在阿纳海姆的迪士尼乐园扮演了《小美人鱼》中的爱丽儿。蕾切尔娇小的身材和宽阔的蓝眼睛意味着她非常适合迪士尼公主的角色。但那些与这对夫妇关系密切的人并没有将这视为童话般的浪漫。他们声称丹尼尔在遇到蕾切尔后变了。
He dropped out of college and his relationship with his family became strained after his parents caught him stealing money. Nevertheless, it was clear that he was crazy about Rachel. It seemed to outsiders as though she called the shots and Daniel would do anything to make her happy. Detectives had taken Rachel in for questioning almost immediately after first arresting Daniel. They were suspicious of the way she'd initially repeated his story about seeing Sam Hare leave the apartment building with a man in a black baseball cap. Rachel had said that she didn't recognize the man, implying she had seen him with her own eyes, despite Daniel now admitting he had made the man up. When queried about her earlier claim, Rachel amended her story to say that Daniel had merely told her about the individual he supposedly saw Sam with, and trusting him, she repeated his version of events verbatim. Rachel adamantly denied knowing that she and Daniel were in financial trouble, insisting that he kept that information from her. But investigators learned that the couple had already been evicted from another apartment building they lived in previously, and had been notified that they faced eviction from Camden Martinique.
他从大学辍学，在父母抓到他偷钱后，他与家人的关系变得紧张。尽管如此，很明显他迷恋蕾切尔。在外人看来，似乎是她在发号施令，而丹尼尔愿意做任何事情来让她高兴。在逮捕丹尼尔后几乎立刻，侦探们就把蕾切尔带去审问。他们对她最初重复丹尼尔的故事的方式感到怀疑，即看到萨姆·黑尔和一个戴着黑色棒球帽的男子离开公寓楼。蕾切尔曾说她不认识那个人，暗示她是亲眼看到他和那个人在一起的，尽管丹尼尔现在承认那个男人是他捏造的。当被问及她早先的说法时，蕾切尔修改了她的说法，称丹尼尔只是告诉了她他据称看到萨姆和谁在一起，而出于信任，她逐字重复了这段经历。蕾切尔坚决否认她和丹尼尔陷入了财务困境，坚称他向她隐瞒了这一信息。但调查人员了解到，这对夫妇之前已经被他们住过的另一栋公寓楼驱逐，并已被通知他们面临来自卡姆登·马蒂尼克的驱逐。
It seemed highly unlikely that Rachel hadn't realized they weren't paying their bills. A witness named Chris also shed more light on the matter. He was a jazz singer who met Daniel and Rachel through mutual friends just a few weeks before the murders. Daniel had told Chris that he was broke and asked to borrow $3,000. Chris agreed to lend him $2,000, but said he'd need to be repaid by Friday, May 21. When that date rolled around, Chris headed over to the couple's apartment to collect his money. Daniel and Rachel were both there, as was their neighbor, Sam Hare. After about 10 minutes, Daniel and Sam left together, with Daniel promising he'd pay Chris when he returned.
蕾切尔没有意识到他们没有付账单，这似乎极不可能。一个名叫克里斯（Chris）的witness也为这件事提供了更多光亮。他是一名爵士歌手，在谋杀案发生前几周通过共同的朋友认识了丹尼尔和蕾切尔。丹尼尔告诉克里斯他破产了，并请求借3000美元。克里斯同意借给他2000美元，但表示必须在5月21日星期五之前还清。当那个日期到来时，克里斯前往这对夫妇的公寓去收回他的钱。丹尼尔和蕾切尔都在那里，他们的邻居萨姆·黑尔也在。大约10分钟后，丹尼尔和萨姆一起离开了，丹尼尔承诺他回来时会付钱给克里斯。
Chris waited at the apartment for several hours, privately wondering what was taking Daniel so long. He chatted with Rachel while she sat at the computer and looked for jobs on Craigslist. Finally, Daniel reappeared by himself. He handed Chris a wad of cash that he said was $400 and promised to repay the rest soon. Chris noticed that Rachel was glaring at Daniel. Eager to escape the apparent tension brewing between the couple, Chris left quickly after pocketing his money. Chris's story placed Sam Hare in the couple's apartment mere hours before his murder, and indicated Daniel had wasted no time in helping himself to Sam's money. It also suggested some hostility between Daniel and Rachel.
克里斯在公寓里等了几个小时，私下里纳闷为什么丹尼尔花这么长时间。他一边和坐在电脑前在Craigslist上找工作的蕾切尔聊天，一边等待。最后，丹尼尔独自一人重新出现了。他递给克里斯一卷现金，说这是400美元，并承诺很快还清剩下的钱。克里斯注意到蕾切尔正怒视着丹尼尔。渴望逃离这对夫妇之间酝酿的明显紧张气氛，克里斯在把钱放进口袋后迅速离开了。克里斯的故事把萨姆·黑尔在谋杀前几小时安排在这对夫妇的公寓里，并表明丹尼尔毫不耽误地占有了萨姆的钱。这也暗示了丹尼尔和蕾切尔之间存在某种敌意。
Rachel had told the police about Daniel leaving with Sam that afternoon too, but in her version, he had only been gone for a brief window of time. She had never mentioned Chris at all. At around midnight that night, Daniel claimed his next victim, Julie Kibouishi. Rachel told police she had been asleep when Daniel snuck out to meet Julie. But records of her online activity revealed something curious. About an hour before the second murder, Rachel had sent a Facebook message to none other than Julie Kibouishi. The message was a reply to a friendly message Julie had sent earlier that day, offering congratulations for Rachel's impending nuptials. At around 11.10pm, Rachel replied, promising that the two of them would catch up after her wedding.
蕾切尔那天下午也告诉警方丹尼尔和萨姆一起离开的事，但在她的版本中，他只离开了一小会儿。她根本没有提到克里斯。大约在那天午夜，丹尼尔夺去了他的下一个受害者——久保石茱莉的生命。蕾切尔告诉警方，当丹尼尔溜出去见茱莉时，她一直在睡觉。但她网络活动的记录揭示了一些奇怪的事情。在大约第二起谋杀案发生前一小时，蕾切尔给久保石茱莉发送了一条Facebook消息。这条消息是对茱莉当天早些时候发送的一条友好消息的回复，祝贺蕾切尔即将举办婚礼。在大约晚上11点10分，蕾切尔回复了，承诺两人将在她的婚礼后聚一聚。
Quote, we'll hang out when everything settles in the summer sun. Police suspected that the plot against Julie had only been concocted after Sam's murder. Daniel had been using Sam's phone after killing him and sent a message to Julie in the afternoon, before his later messages begging her to come over. In the earlier text, he wrote that he was helping his neighbour Dan. Perhaps this slip-up linking Daniel to Sam had led to Julie becoming the target for Daniel's cover-up. Police suspected that Rachel had been in on the plan. Perhaps her Facebook message to Julie was a kind of alibi to profess her ignorance. Friends and acquaintances of the couple had noticed both of them behaving strangely in the immediate aftermath of the two murders.
“当一切在夏日的阳光下安定下来时，我们会一起出去玩的。”警方怀疑针对茱莉的阴谋是在萨姆被谋杀后才策划的。丹尼尔在杀害萨姆后一直在使用萨姆的手机，并在下午给茱莉发了一条消息，之后才发了恳求她过来的短信。在早些时候的短信中，他写道他正在帮他的邻居丹。也许这个将丹尼尔与萨姆联系起来的口误导致茱莉成为丹尼尔掩盖罪行的目标。警方怀疑蕾切尔参与了这项计划。也许她发给茱莉的Facebook消息是一种伪装无知的 alibi（不在场证明）。这对夫妇的朋友和熟人在两起谋杀案发生后的直接反应中都注意到他们两个人的行为很奇怪。
As detailed in the book Killing for You, one of their co-stars in the production of Nine said Rachel seemed sad and distant on the night of Friday, May 21. In one scene that required her to act upset, Rachel actually cried on stage and continued crying afterwards as well. She had never wept during that scene before. At the following night's show, Rachel's co-star asked her how she was. Rachel allegedly replied, My friend is missing. I think she's missing. I think she's dead. I think my friend did it. This conversation took place almost five hours before Julie Kibouishi's body was found by Steve Hare. When Daniel Wozniak called Rachel from custody less than a week later, their entire conversation was recorded. Rachel made it clear throughout the call that she was aware of this.
正如《为你杀戮》一书中所述，他们在音乐剧《九》中的一位联合主演说，蕾切尔在5月21日星期五晚上看起来悲伤而疏离。在一个需要她表现出沮丧的场景中，蕾切尔实际上在舞台上哭了，并且在之后也一直哭泣。她以前在那个场景中从来没有哭过。在第二晚的演出中，蕾切尔的联合主演问她感觉怎么样。蕾切尔据称回答说：“我的朋友失踪了。我想她失踪了。我想她死了。我想我的朋友干的。”这场对话发生在大约五个小时前，在史蒂夫·黑尔发现久保石茱莉的尸体之前。当丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克在不到一周后从拘留所打电话给蕾切尔时，他们的整个对话都被录音了。蕾切尔在整个通话过程中都明确表示她意识到了这一点。
When she informed Daniel that she was notifying a detective that his brother Tim was in possession of evidence, she made a point of stating, I need to call him and let him know before they catch me on this recording device because it looks like I'm not trying to tell them right away. Daniel tried to convince her to stay quiet, to which Rachel retorted. You realize they're recording this phone conversation anyways. You're being an absolute ass to try and lie again. In a dejected voice, Daniel said, Now I'm really dead. Baby, you're already dead, Rachel replied. Although detectives believed Rachel could be a co-conspirator and not just an accessory, they didn't have enough evidence to back up their theory. They also suspected that Tim Wozniak knew more than he was letting on.
当她通知丹尼尔她正在通知侦探他的弟弟蒂姆持有证据时，她特意指出：“我需要打电话给他，在他们用这个录音设备抓到我之前让他知道，因为这看起来好像我没有马上告诉他们。”丹尼尔试图说服她保持安静，对此蕾切尔反驳道：“你意识到他们无论如何都在录制这个电话交谈吗？你再次试图撒谎，简直是个混蛋。”丹尼尔用沮丧的声音说：“现在我真的死定了。”“宝贝，你已经死定了，”蕾切尔回答道。尽管侦探们认为蕾切尔可能是共同谋杀犯而不仅仅是从犯，但他们没有足够的证据来支持他们的理论。他们还怀疑蒂姆·沃兹尼亚克知道的比他透露的要多。
When Sam Hare's father, Steve, saw a photo of Tim in the news, he suddenly remembered something that had happened while he was trying to find his son. Steve had gone to the Long Beach pizza parlor where Sam's card had been used and waited outside for any sign of Sam or his vehicle. He never saw either, but he did notice an agitated looking man inside the restaurant, pacing back and forth while on his cell phone. Upon seeing the photo of Tim Wozniak, Steve realized he had been that man. Prosecutors didn't want to proceed with Tim Wozniak or Rachel Buffett's charges until Daniel's trial was done. In February 2013, while court proceedings were still ongoing, Rachel accepted an invitation to appear on the television talk show Doctor Phil. She said that she was doing so to clear her name, but some believed she was trying to boost her profile with a view to furthering her acting career. Throughout the interview, Rachel insisted she had known nothing about the crimes until her fiance was arrested.
当萨姆·黑尔的父亲史蒂夫在新闻中看到蒂姆的照片时，他突然想起在他试图寻找儿子时发生的事情。史蒂夫曾去过使用萨姆卡的长滩披萨店，并在外面等待萨姆或他的车辆的任何迹象。他从来没有看到任何一个，但他确实注意到餐厅里有一个看起来很焦虑的男子，一边打手机一边来回踱步。在看到蒂姆·沃兹尼亚克的照片时，史蒂夫意识到他就是那个男子。检察官不想在丹尼尔的审判结束前推进对蒂姆·沃兹尼亚克或蕾切尔·巴菲特的指控。2013年2月，当法庭诉讼仍在进行时，蕾切尔接受了电视脱口秀节目《菲尔博士》（Doctor Phil）的邀请。她说她这样做是为了洗清自己的清白，但一些人认为她是想通过提高知名度来促进她的演艺生涯。在整个采访过程中，蕾切尔坚称她对这些罪行一无所知，直到她的未婚夫被捕。
When confronted with the fact that she had told the same story as Daniel about seeing a suspicious individual in a black hat, she insisted she was only guilty of trusting Daniel. Rachel told host Phil McGraw and the studio audience that Daniel had been a pathological liar with secrets she had known nothing about. Discussing the impact of the double homicide, Rachel stated, It's absolutely horrific, but I think I know I'm not the main victim. Sam and Julie were the main victims, and then I think even secondary would be their families. I am after all of that. I realized that. Steve Hare was seated amongst the studio audience and given the opportunity to address Rachel directly. He was horrified by her decision to appear on national television and told her as much. I was aghast when I get a call saying you're going on TV. My son is dead. He was cut up into pieces, and you come on here and go on the TV stations. Poor me. That offends me.
当被问及她曾像丹尼尔一样讲述看到一个戴着黑色帽子的可疑个人的故事时，她坚称自己唯一的罪过就是信任丹尼尔。蕾切尔告诉主持人菲尔·麦格劳（Phil McGraw）和演播室观众，丹尼尔是一个病态的说谎者，拥有她一无所知的秘密。在讨论双重谋杀案的影响时，蕾切尔表示：“这绝对是可怕的，但我认为我知道我不是主要受害者。萨姆和茱莉是主要受害者，然后我认为次要的甚至是他们的家属。我在所有这些之后。我意识到了这一点。”史蒂夫·黑尔坐在演播室观众中，并有机会直接向蕾切尔讲话。他对她决定出现在全国电视上的决定感到震惊，并对她直言不讳。“当我接到电话说你要上电视时，我感到震惊。我儿子死了。他被切成碎片，而你来到这里上了电视台。‘可怜的我。’这冒犯了我。”
Rachel told Steve she understood his feelings, but denied presenting herself as a victim, pointing out that she hadn't gone to Hollywood in an attempt to sell her story. Not yet. Steve replied. After Daniel Wozniak was convicted, prosecutors finally proceeded with taking Rachel Buffett to court on two felony charges of accessory to murder after the fact. They accused her of lying to and misleading investigators about what Daniel had done and what exactly she knew. Rachel contested the charges, but in November 2018, a jury found her guilty. She was sentenced to two years and eight months in Orange County jail, with credit for time she had already served while awaiting her trial. The final six months would be served on probation. Once again, the victim's families were given the chance to address the court. Steve Hare, who was convinced Rachel's involvement went above what she was charged with, stated,
蕾切尔告诉史蒂夫她理解他的感受，但否认自己表现得像个受害者，并指出她并没有去好莱坞试图兜售她的故事。“还没有，”史蒂夫回答道。在丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克被定罪后，检察官终于将蕾切尔·巴菲特带上法庭，面临两项谋杀后从犯的重罪指控。他们指控她对丹尼尔所做的事情以及她确切知道的事情向调查人员撒谎并误导。蕾切尔对这些指控提出了异议，但在2018年11月，陪审团裁定她有罪。她被判处在奥兰治县监狱服刑两年八个月，并折抵她在等待审判期间已经服刑的时间。最后六个月将在缓刑期间度过。受害者的家属再次获得了向法庭陈述的机会。坚信蕾切尔的参与超越了她被指控范围的史蒂夫·黑尔表示：
Rachel knew exactly what she was doing. She could have saved us eight years and six months of grief. Julie Kibouishi's mother, Junco, asked Rachel directly, All these years, have you shown remorse? No. None. Daniel Wozniak's brother, Tim, had also been charged as an accessory after the fact for holding onto the murder weapon and other crucial evidence that Daniel had given him. He struck a plea deal with prosecutors, pleading guilty in exchange for a sentence of 10 days in jail that had already been served and probation. He was also required to enroll and participate in an anger management program.
“蕾切尔清楚地知道她在做什么。她本可以让我们免受八年六个月的悲痛。”久保石茱莉的母亲纯子直接问蕾切尔：“这些年来，你表现出悔意了吗？没有。一点也没有。”丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克的弟弟蒂姆也因持有丹尼尔给他的凶器和其他关键证据而被指控为从犯。他与检察官达成了一项认罪协议，承认有罪以换取在监狱服刑10天（已服刑）和缓刑的判决。他还被要求报名并参加愤怒管理项目。
Although prosecutors were determined that Daniel Wozniak received the death penalty, it is uncertain whether this sentence will ever be carried out. In 2006, the state of California placed a moratorium on capital punishment after a federal court ruled that a three-drug lethal injection may cause inhumane suffering. In the years since, the matter has been pursued at both state and federal levels, but the moratorium remains. In 2019, California Governor Gavin Newsom signed an executive order granting all death penalty inmates a reprieve. More than 700 individuals technically remain on death row throughout the state, despite the indefinite pause on executions. In July 2021, News broke that Daniel Wozniak had been transferred out of death row in San Quentin State Prison and was now serving his sentence at Salinas Valley, a lower security facility. The transfer was made as part of a pilot program by California's Department of Corrections and Rehabilitation. Steve Hare wasn't officially notified of the relocation. He learned of it from a blogger who remains in regular contact with Daniel.
尽管检察官决心让丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克被判处死刑，但这一判决是否会真正执行尚不确定。2006年，在联邦法院裁定三药注射死刑可能造成不人道的痛苦之后，加利福尼亚州对死刑实施了暂停令。在此后的几年里，该问题在州和联邦两级都得到了跟进，但暂停令依然存在。2019年，加州州长加文·纽森（Gavin Newsom）签署了一项行政命令，给予所有死刑犯缓刑。尽管对死刑的无限期暂停，全州技术上仍有700多名个人在死刑犯行列中。2021年7月，有消息传出，丹尼尔·沃兹尼亚克已被从圣昆廷州立监狱（San Quentin State Prison）的死刑牢房转移，目前正在较低安全级别的萨利纳斯谷（Salinas Valley）服刑。这次调动是加州惩教与康复部的一项试点项目的一部分。史蒂夫·黑尔没有被正式通知这次搬迁。他是从一个与丹尼尔保持定期联系的博主那里得知的。
Speaking to the Orange County Register, Steve described the decision as a kick in the stomach, quote, It would have been good for them to at least warn me. If I could, I would kill him myself, but that won't happen, so I want the harshest punishment possible. Due to his service in the United States Army, Sam Hare received a military funeral with full honours and was laid to rest at Riverside National Cemetery. Steve and Raquel Hare visit their son's graveside every week. Sam was known to be the life of the party, someone who was always smiling and laughing. He was also quick to stand up for what he believed was right. When friends heard that he had been murdered, they knew that whoever had attacked him must have done so from behind. They wouldn't have stood a chance if they tackled Sam front on. But those who were close to Sam also knew his softer side. When Julie Kibuishi told her mother about Sam, she described him as a big teddy bear. As well as being an aspiring fashion designer, Julie Kibuishi was a talented dancer.
史蒂夫在接受《奥兰治县纪事报》采访时，将这个决定形容为“当胸一击”，原话是：“他们至少应该提前警告我一声，这对外公对他们都有好处。如果可以的话，我会亲手杀了他，但这是不可能的，所以我希望得到最严厉的惩罚。”由于萨姆·黑尔曾在美国陆军服役，他获得了享有全套军礼的军事葬礼，并被安葬在河滨国家公墓。史蒂夫和拉奎尔·黑尔夫妇每周都会去探望儿子的墓地。萨姆生前是聚会上的开心果，总是面带微笑、爽朗大笑。他也是一个敢于为自己认同的正义挺身而出的人。当朋友们听说他遇害时，他们就知道任何袭击他的人一定是从背后偷袭的。如果正面交锋，凶手根本没有胜算。但熟悉萨姆的人也知道他温柔的一面。朱莉·吉武石向母亲提起萨姆时，把他形容为一只大泰迪熊。朱莉·吉武石不仅是一位有抱负的时装设计师，还是一位才华横溢的舞者。
It was a hobby she had picked up at the age of five, and she went on to pursue it as a student at Orange County School of the Arts. One of her teachers later said that dancing and music were deeply spiritual for Julie. Her performances were described with the same adjectives that people used to describe her personality. Fun, bright and vivacious. Julie's remains were taken to Japan by her grieving family, in accordance with the Japanese tradition that unmarried children be reunited with their ancestors upon passing. Prior to departing, her family asked the police if they could have the tiara she was wearing on the night she was killed. Her brother Taka had given it to her hours beforehand after asking her to be a bridesmaid at his wedding. Julie was so excited that she put the tiara on right away and wore it for the rest of the night. The precious memento was cremated with her body.
跳舞是她五岁时就培养起来的爱好，后来她作为奥兰治县艺术学院的学生继续深造。她的一位老师后来评价说，舞蹈和音乐对朱莉来说具有深刻的灵性。人们用形容她个性的那些词汇来描述她的表演：有趣、阳光、充满活力。悲痛欲绝的家人按照日本未婚子女离世后要与祖先团聚的传统，将朱莉的遗体运回了日本。在启程之前，她的家人向警方询问是否可以拿回她遇害当晚佩戴的皇冠。她的哥哥贵（Taka）在几小时前邀请她在他婚礼上当伴娘后，将这顶皇冠送给了她。朱莉兴奋不已，立刻戴上了皇冠，并在当晚剩下的时间里一直戴着。这件珍贵的纪念品和她的遗体一起被火化了。
A replica of the tiara is displayed in Junko Kibuishi's bedroom, alongside an urn that contains some of her daughter's ashes. Thank you for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这顶皇冠的复制品陈列在纯子·吉武石的卧室里，旁边放着一个装有她女儿部分骨灰的骨灰盒。感谢您的观看！本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。